tell martay
rips one way foul goodness
we haven't seen cattell tee off on one
like that in a while
and had to feel good now keep it fair
del marte 29 games all of them starts
without hitting a home run
it's last homer in fact his only homer
this year july 30
against the dodgers at chase field
makes another big one and this one might
stay fair after all
martay his second diamondback strike
first in san francisco
not often bobby you see a guy go up
there trying to hit a home run but it
sure
looked like that's what cattell had in
mind there just looking for something he
could get in the air to left field the
first one he was just a little bit too
quick on but this one he is right on
time
dickerson now will take off walker's
gonna play behind him at first
dickerson goes and belt lines this one
fair down the right field line
it's gonna kick to calhoun and they're
gonna
wave in dickerson here's the throw home
and it's gonna be not in time
is belt ties it up with a double down on
the right field line
do it ron that's as good a call
from a third base coach as you'll see
you have to remember that one of the
best assist arms in baseball
is in right field tonight with cole
calhoun now watch
before they catch a break it kicks away
now calhoun's got to readjust
i mean he's got alex dickerson who's got
average speed at best
and he sends them home a nice call for
mortise
now they're loaded back-to-back bases on
balls ahead of brandon crawford
fastball right field cole calhoun is
there
the escapes with only one run scoring
there were two hits in the inning they
leave them loaded and after one in san
francisco are knotted at one
here's martay first time up homer chance
for another rbi here
makes another rip and hits it right
through longoria varshall coming around
third he will score cattell marte has
smashed two baseballs so far tonight in
two at bats
a home run and a double he's knocked in
two run here's solano who drew a walk in
the first
hit up the middle ahmed
double clutch to throw and he beat it
out and this game is tied
you could see the double clutch and
solano sniffing it out and it's two to
two
that is a rare defensive mistake from a
gold glover
you're never faster than when you're
trying to
leg out a ground ball in the infield to
get an rbi
second and third nobody out andy young
no for one
got him change up and you cannot control
a better one
a little two-strike surprise and andy
young completely bites
2-2 to dalton varshall swinging in a lie
drive base hit that's going to score a
couple
one is in here comes the other runner
around the plate cut off
two run single don varsio and the
diamondbacks slate it
by a score four to two his first two
runs batted in the major league
so bart with a lead off single here in
the fourth and here's dubai
he shook off about four sides to get to
this pitch hooked on the left field line
and a fair ball bart is on the move is
the castro is going to dig it out and
they're going to wave in bart
and the throw home is going to be late
and duvan makes it a 4-3 game
open up the giant fifth against sam
coonrod
cole calhoun did he get enough it will
stay in the yard for yastremski here
comes walker
escobar tags as well and there's the rbi
for cole calhoun making five three
diamond beds
escobar in third with one out for nick
ahmed nick is two for two
[Applause]
ahmed dunks went into left field this
will get another run in
nick three for three make it six three
diamond bags news crawford who's over
two
crawford goes the other way and he's got
a base hit
floors will score easily so crawford
just goes right against the shift and
that's a big run at 6-4
and the pitch to walker here it is
hit up the middle solano is going to
keep this one
no he's going to throw him out with a
great play and hector rundown is the new
pitcher facing brandon belt delta high
drive to right
it is here
as it bounces into the water and it's a
one-run game
and he is seeing it big home run number
six for belt
bases are loaded of giants
this is lifted out to right field cole
calhoun duggar is at third
and he will stay there not deep enough
and they have
hung up at second base and he's out of
the baseline
a double play turned by the diamondbacks
two outs and it's left to brandon
crawford
there goes robertson swaying in a miss
and a fastball
kevin ginkel gets the save could tell
marta with a four
hit night